[Music]
the tnt
for
its competitors for Europe that no
action of its implementation and that the
situation worsens
certain museums or
innovations like the key at the sides
[Music]
camille I am 16 years old I come from Toulouse
in france and i am a student in the
first class at the lycée
charles bourgeois you
think you are trying to do
sometimes change paris quick nov jodido
carillon people all of the world it's
us and nature are at war by alan
gross big red one thing  he is a must
read more morato h internal here let go
to the ladies still problem amine aoudia
chief at the relay
the tasers vologe imacs in london
iconic to the authorities this case of failure
to the people she was going to
fail date
each
for me he  you have to approach
environmental protection in two ways
first you have to educate the
next generation and empower the adults
of tea a das killed a woman and most
hid
roundhouse principle as of date she is where
the tocs  toc aux sagas vonn got annoyed
socializing in lomé monopoly
the hiding show ben the tycoon entourage
is that each branch you think is
going to
be privatized
what i would like to improve in europe
in the field of health and
homogeneity between  the countries for equal access
to care in
each country of the European Union
regardless of their social background, their income,
their place of residence
I proposed the installation of
free hygienic protection
in schools in  all
the countries of the european union
at this time
it is important that as a young
woman my voice is heard just like
that of an adult and i hope that it
continues at low level and tears them
from the usa where the kingdom of  conferences
on the ordinary tornado or elsewhere born
in lyon their audacity and their taste for
conferences
[Music]